schwarber checks in slugging
5 19. batting average in the 240 range
now
2-2 now and schwarber launches one to
right see
you later
later oh my goodness
his fifth homer leading off a game for
the natch this year
and now he's a 20 home run guy
poteet gives up his sixth of the year
yeah you can see it right there a
hanging curve ball
middle middle and
my goodness an absolute blast
in the upper part of the upper deck
and the runner on the move swinging a
miss look at that throw from jan gomes
at his knees
unbelievable what he's doing with the
baseball this year
so it's a strike him out throw him out
double play john gomes
just now to the dog i thought the
marlins might check something
but he tailed that throw perfectly to
the right side of the bag
yep and another victim yongo
[Music]
breaking ball ripped out into left
center
got to pitch up josh did not miss it
next up is victor robles
3-2 now harrison
he was holding roblaise was taking and
the nets
have two aboard at the bottom of the
order somebody says on twitter when are
they going to start just walking this
guy
well that's okay then you got to face
trey turner
to center again
see you later it's like a video game bob
the nats lead 4-nothing
and there are people watching on tv and
in the ballpark
down in miami who are in disbelief
and two of them are sitting next to each
other right here
perfect swing that we've been seeing oh
seems like
once the game
on a pitch up trey turner is going to
get himself on base
hit number 91 for trey turner
trey is so good with two strikes you can
see he gets his foot down early
lets the ball travel on this fastball up
laces the line drive into right field
juan struck out on a slider up
right over the heart of the plate first
time he had just seen a fastball down
around the knees
he sees that one low and trey turner is
going to score on this ball
deepest part of the ballpark trey can
cruise home
one solo with a ringing double
and the nets lead five to nothing and he
wanted to a tone in a hurry well he
didn't want the umpire to determine his
fate he was ready
fastball 111 miles an hour off the bat
and watch as it picks up speed
here and kicks past martay no chance to
cut that one off
don't have to run the bases the way he's
swinging the bat right now
you don't get judged there no just keep
making left turns
he did come up empty on a change up on
3-1
so now it's 3-2 and he goes right back
to it the change-up and poteet
solves schwarber
here's ross detweiler in his 28th game
and facing the team that drafted him
sixth overall back in 2007.
and again there there absolutely have
been hiccups along the way
to this point no bullpen has a zero era
but for the marlins it feels like the
the a and b
bullpen if you will as det wilder gets
back to back strikeouts here in the
sixth inning
that their a and b bullpen is like the
first wave of high leverage
and then the second wave and i mean that
in a very positive way that they have
multiple ways to get
through schwarber in the sixth schwarber
in the eighth
right
that's in there for a called strike
three so two homers to start the night
two strikeouts his last
couple of times and detweiler strikes
out the side
in the sixth
and he will see the tailing action of
the fastball
victor robles and trey turner have each
walked twice in this game tonight
on the double back in the second he
unleashes another line drive
that's gonna plug the gap watch trey run
from first to home for the second time
tonight
one soto sends trey turner and the nets
lead
six to nothing elevated sinker from
zac pop and laced into right center
field by juan soto
and this is an easy first the home jog
for trey turner
and no trouble reading that one
one and two to castro
got a pitch inside that's a fair ball
it'll take two long throws
and the second one is air mail
so juan soto is coming home
it's going to be
seven to nothing
echoes off of miller then toward short
no play for turner
that should be it right there
congratulations luis martey
pumps his fists into the air for obvious
reasons
[Music]
see biggie rose celebrating him now the
marlins have two on and nobody out for
jazz
two-two on the way as jazz unloads
that is a three-run home run to right
center field
[Applause]
they so desperately need his offense
his power and his ability certainly on
display
right here
2-2 with two outs
and driven to right center soto there
and the nats have won five in a row